[Musique]
dans le cadre de la Semaine artistique
chinoise dont le thème cette année est
la Chine au présent les Réunionnais ont
pu assister à un spectacle de l'Opéra de
Pékin sur la légende du serpent blanc
deux expositions ont également été mises
en place au musée léonirx et à la villa
de la
région c'est une initiative lancée par
une fédération des siècles littéraires
et artistiques chinois chaque année il
choisit un itinéraire à l'étranger pour
donner les spectacles exposer les photos
tableaux et cetera donc c'est dans
plutôt pour promouvoir les échanges
culturels entre la Chine et les autres
pays plus de 50 artistes de l'Opéra de
Pékin ont fait le déplacement à la
Réunion pour de représentation l'une au
théâtre de champ-fleuy l'autre au
théâtre Luc Dona au tampon
c'est une légende très connue qui a une
longue histoire en Chine c'est une
légende
d'amour l'Opéra de Pékin est un art
représentatif de la Chine on l'appelle
le trésor
national nous avons souhaité faire venir
ici l'Opéra de Pékin pour la communauté
chinoise de la Réunion c'est l'occasion
pour eux de retrouver leur racine et
nous espérons également tous les
réunionnés vont apprécier notre
spectacle c'est une très belle occasion
de faire découvrir nos habitudes nos
traditions et notre
culture les deux expositions intitulées
panorama du xingjang proposent des
photographies et des peintures chinois
qui représent les paysages et la
population très folklorique de cette
région située à l'extrême ouest de la
Chine pour le Conseil départemental qui
a mis à disposition deux de ses
équipements culturels
et le théâtre de Champfleur laavenue de
l'Opéra de Pékin est une chance
l'occasion de mieux découvrir la culture
chinoise qui fait partie intégrante de
la Réunion
mettre à la portée des Réunionnais des
Réunionnaises l'opéra des Pékin qui est
patr mondial de l'UNESCO est une chance
extraordinaire certes ce n'est pas un
art facile d'accès mais je crois que
justement on a besoin plus que jamais de
tout faire pour comprendre l'omme de
faire pour les velotes et cet autre là
on le connaît un peu puisque ce sont des
Chinois et les chinois sont partie
intégrante de la culture réonnaise donc
il est extrêmement important en plus de
l'Opéra de pain de venir si cette belle
exposition ici au parce que il aura
matière à découvrir matière à apprécier
et matière encore une fois à renforcer
les liens entre la Réunion et la Chine
les deux expositions sont disponibles au
musée Léon d'erx jusqu'au 31 juillet et
à la villa de l'AR région jusqu'au 29
[Musique]
juillet